see I'm still an architect at heart so
goals and means you know you have an
idea and then everything has to go
towards that idea and if your initial
idea is really strong things fit into
place you know so the first most
important step is to really work on the
idea and make it so that it can define
the limits of what you want to choose
the creative process continues until the
very end you know when you conceived an
exhibition you know i'll tell you the
process you first go to your chief
curator moma discuss it with him with
your colleagues then you go in front of
the exhibition's committee which is a
bunch of tough cookies I'm part of it to
you discuss it with them they come back
without it with questions they really
they're very you know it's tough love
there and if it goes through them and
then you move on then you're basically
on your own which is beautiful and tough
at the same time the way I usually
define the job of a curator moment is
you think of the curator is both the
director and the producer of a movie and
moments the studios so you're
responsible to moma for the whole budget
you know for the quality of what you put
together and you make sure that you
don't embarrass moma you know so you
have to kind of fostering that you have
to continue the mission you have to be
part of that family and of that
particular idea but then you're
responsible for the whole production so
it's very creative and very practical at
the same time you have to work on a
catalogue you have to work on a website
you have to work on the installation as
the curator you're responsible for all
choices including the tablecloths for
the opening you know it really is very
very detailed and very exciting
especially when you get towards the end
you're on the floor doing the
installation and what you have in in
return is one of the best teams
production teams in the world so we tend
to do most working house we have
designers in-house we have the best
carpenters and painters so they really
can do everything in this particular
occasion I chose to have a graphic
designer for the catalogue from
Amsterdam you're my bomb
because she's one of the best book
designers in the world and I wanted her
to take this strong idea and make it
become reality so for design and elastic
mind Irma is the catalog designer and
then we have a website designer in Japan
in Tokyo Yoga Nakamura the company is
called you got once again he already had
expressed some of the basic ideas that
are in the show the idea of scale the
idea of elasticity and also we thought
it would be interesting to have Europe
Japan and the United States since this
is an exhibition about how the world has
changed and how we've become much more
elastic in our everyday life so in this
particular case we're outside but
everything else it is inside MoMA and
the creative process really as far as
I'm concerned is also in the budget you
know I do believe that what
differentiates something like film or
something like design from the other
arts is that you always have to deal
with very very practical mundane
problems and that's what keeps you at
bay and what makes sure that in the end
the project is as universal and as easy
to communicate as possible
you